[Música]
renuncia el secretario de relaciones
exteriores de México Marcelo ebrardejará
el cargo desde la próxima semana y se
concentrará en su búsqueda de
convertirse en el candidato del partido
oficialista Morena para suceder a Andrés
Manuel López Obrador en las
presidenciales de 2024
sigue creciendo la lista de aspirantes
republicanos a la casa blanca el ex
gobernador del estado de Nueva Jersey
Chris Christi buscará ser quien
represente al partido en las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024 y para ellos se
enfrentará a su antigua Aliado Donald
Trump
encuentran restos humanos de un posible
desaparecido durante la dictadura
militar de Uruguay el hallazgo se dio en
el predio de un Batallón del ejército A
las afueras de Montevideo donde se
llevan a cabo trabajos de búsqueda de
personas detenidas durante este periodo
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en Francia 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz iniciamos en
México el secretario de relaciones
exteriores Marcelo ebrard dejará su
cargo a partir del próximo lunes el jefe
de la diplomacia mexicana buscará ser el
candidato del partido oficialista Morena
de Cara a las elecciones presidenciales
de 2024 pero tendrá competencia otro de
los personajes más populares para este
puesto es la actual alcaldesa de Ciudad
de México Claudia sheinbaum desde la
capital mexicana nuestro corresponsal
Mario carbonel con los detalles
el secretario de relaciones exteriores
Marcelo ebrard casaubón anunció que
dejará el cargo de canciller a partir
del próximo lunes 12 de junio para
dedicarse de lleno a la búsqueda de la
candidatura presidencial de su partido
Morena Esta es una de las condiciones
que el canciller había sugerido para
todos aquellos quienes aspiren a esta
candidatura dentro de morena que dejen
el cargo que actualmente Ocupan que se
organicen debates para exponer sus ideas
y que la encuesta que se realizará para
definir al candidato sea amplia
transparente y verificable hasta el
momento es el único de los aspirantes
presidenciales de morena que ha dejado
el cargo y no se prevé que sus
contrincantes hagan lo propio en el
corto plazo la jefa de gobierno Claudia
sheinbaum ha anunciado en distintas
ocasiones que no ve necesidad de
separarse del cargo por ahora en su
oportunidad y también después de lo
anunciado por ebrar el secretario de
gobernación adana Augusto López a través
de su cuenta de Twitter entender pues no
se refirió específicamente al tema pero
dio a entender que un paisano suyo él es
de Tabasco igual que el presidente López
Obrador le ha enseñado que hay que
equilibrar la razón y la pasión y que
los tiempos del señor son los adecuados
serenidad y paciencia lo cual se ha
interpretado como que no va a dejar el
cargo
ebrar casaubón En su mensaje dejó en
claro que no va a renunciar a morena
como se había especulado en algunos
sectores Pues dijo que se siente
orgulloso de pertenecer al movimiento
que ellos denominan la cuarta
transformación y se dijo agradecido con
el presidente de la república por tantos
años de trabajo juntos se espera que el
próximo domingo que haya el Consejo
Nacional de morena se defina ya las
reglas para esta para esta Selección del
candidato presidencial de ese partido
cambiamos de tema vamos a Estados Unidos
cada día se alarga la lista de
personajes que buscan convertirse en el
candidato del partido republicano a las
elecciones presidenciales de 2024 este
martes fue el turno de Chris Christi
exgobernador del estado de Nueva Jersey
Quién era Aliado de Donald Trump pero
ahora es uno de sus críticos de esta
manera Cristi desafía a Trump por la
nominación republicana a la que también
aspiran figuras como el gobernador de
Florida ron de santis el ex
vicepresidente Mike pence y la ex
gobernadora de Carolina del Sur Nicky
Haley
Donald Trump nos hizo más pequeños
dividiéndonos aún más y enfrentando a un
grupo contra otro diferentes grupos se
han enfrentado contra diferentes grupos
todos los días
no existen los votantes de Trump él no
los posee no se apoderó de ellos no son
uno de sus edificios no son uno de sus
casinos fallidos en Nueva Jersey no son
esa ruina que tienen las Vegas no las
posee votaron por él Por cierto yo voté
por él dos veces en mi mente soy
entonces un votante de Trump ahora por
supuesto que no
y continúa la ofensiva de la comisión de
bolsas y valores de Estados Unidos
contra las principales plataformas de
intercambio de criptomonedas tras
demandar a binance la sec ahora también
interpuso una querella contra coinbase
acusa la plataforma de operar sin
licencia en el país los detalles a
continuación
aumenta la presión contra las
plataformas de criptomonedas justo Un
día después de demandar a binance la
comisión de bolsa y valores de Estados
Unidos tiene en la mira a coinbase la
mayor bolsa de criptomonedas del país
por operar presuntamente como corredor
no registrado coinbase será plenamente
consciente de la aplicabilidad de las
leyes federales de valores a sus
actividades comerciales pero
deliberadamente se negó a seguirlas si
bien las decisiones calculadas de
coinbase pueden haberle permitido ganar
miles de millones lo ha hecho expensas
de los inversores privandoles de las
protecciones a las que tienen derecho
coinbase contraatacó culpando al enfoque
reguladores la confianza de la sec en un
enfoque basado únicamente en la
aplicación de la ley en ausencia de
normas claras para el sector de los
activos digitales está perjudicando la
competitividad económica de Estados
Unidos y a empresas como coinbase que
han demostrado su compromiso con el
cumplimiento Mientras tanto binance la
mayor bolsa de criptomonedas del mundo y
su fundador fueron acusados el lunes de
gestionar una bolsa ilegal en Estados
Unidos y de engañar a los inversores
vainas ha argumentado durante mucho
tiempo que no está sujeta a las leyes
estadounidenses porque no tiene una sede
física en el país sin embargo Estados
Unidos reforzó su control sobre las
plataformas de criptomonedas
especialmente desde la quiebra de ftx en
noviembre del año pasado la Unión
Europea también promulgó recientemente
una ley histórica con normas para este
sector
el humo de los incendios forestales en
Canadá ya llegó a la capital del país
Ottawa videos publicados en redes
sociales muestran una neblina naranja en
la ciudad y las autoridades ambientales
emitieron alertas sobre la calidad del
aire en las provincias de Ontario donde
está la capital en la vecina provincia
de Quebec las llamas siguen activas allí
También en Alberta y la gravedad es tal
que Canadá podría experimentar la peor
temporada de incendios de su historia y
en Uruguay se produjo un nuevo hallazgo
de lo que se cree son restos de un
posible desaparecido durante la
dictadura militar que vivió el país
entre 1973 y 1985 esto en medio de las
tareas de excavación que se llevan a
cabo en un predio del Batallón 14 del
ejército a las afueras de Montevideo de
confirmarse sería una de las 197
personas detenidas desaparecidas durante
este periodo desde punta del este
nuestra corresponsal Karina dalmas con
los detalles los restos de un posible
desaparecido durante la dictadura Cívico
militar ocurrida en Uruguay entre 19
73 y 1985 fueron hallados dentro del
Batallón número 14 del ejército uruguayo
en las afueras de Montevideo según
informaron Fuentes oficiales el
presidente del Instituto Nacional de
Derechos Humanos wilder tayler informó
que se encontró al menos un cráneo y
restos óseos te lo dijo en rueda de
prensa Este martes ome también Indicó
que llevará al menos 48 horas
dilucidar si se encuentran más restos
humanos dentro del Batallón y varios
días más identificar los ya hallados
el Instituto realiza excavaciones en el
lugar por parte de un grupo de
antropólogos
la asociación de madres y familiares de
desaparecidos durante la dictadura
uruguaya Fueron informados por medio del
fiscal de crímenes de lesa humanidad y
también por el Instituto Nacional de
Derechos Humanos de confirmarse que se
trata de los restos de un desaparecido
sería uno de las 197 personas detenidas
desaparecidas durante la dictadura en
Uruguay bajo el marco del plan represivo
denominado plan Cóndor impulsado por
Estados Unidos en Latinoamérica en los
años
70 y 80 de confirmarse el hallazgo este
sería el quinto ocurrido en el país
hasta aquí este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]